the leader of the Wagner mercenary group
of guinea pig ocean says his Fighters
will not turn themselves in and Russia's
president is deeply mistaken by accusing
them of committing treason right now a
convoy of Wagner Fighters is reported to
be heading north along the M4 Motorway
towards Moscow earlier They seized
control of military headquarters in the
southern city of rostov ondon President
of Vladimir Putin described the
Rebellion as a stab in the back he's
vowed to punish the mutiny's leaders the
Tashan leader and Putin Ally ramzan
khajirov says he's sending forces to the
area to help Michael Apple begins her
coverage
for that one Wagner's forces occupied
Russia's military headquarters in roster
Von Dawn early on Saturday the group
claimed to have shot down a Russian
military helicopter and in turn a Wagner
military Convoy came under Fire on a
highway outside the city of voro Nash
pictures also emerged of almost 200
Russian troops surrendering to Wagner
video of The Mercenaries on the streets
of the city in southern Russia
immediately flooded social media some
mercenaries even finding the time to
order fast food
it wasn't long before Russia's president
was addressing the nation and vowing
retribution
we will protect our people and our
statehood from any threats including
internal betrayal and what we are facing
is betrayal exorbitant Ambitions and
personal interests led to treason
the Russian leader spelling out just how
serious he thinks the threat from Wagner
is
any internal turmoil is a deadly threat
to our statehood to us as a nation this
is a blow to Russia to our people
Russia's defense Ministry appealed to
Wagner fighters to abandon progression
saying they'd been tricked into what was
described as their leaders criminal
adventure and participation in an armed
Rebellion
tension between Wagner and the kremlin's
Armed Forces escalated during the Battle
of bakmut where the mercenaries played a
crucial role in the drawn out fighter
capture the city
Prague accused the Russian army
commanders of deliberately withholding
ammunition and other supplies from his
men
in an audio recording Prague denied
Putin's accusation of treason
we are patriots of our homeland we had
been fighting and we are fighting now no
one is going to turn themselves in on
demand of the president FSB or anyone
else because we do not want any more of
our country to live in corruption lies
and bureaucracy this is why we are the
Patriots and those who are against us
are the ones surrounding the scumbags
police raided Wagner's headquarters in
Saint Petersburg while in Moscow
security has been tightened and what's
described as a counter-terrorism state
of emergency imposed Mike leppel Al
Jazeera
we've got four correspondents across
Russia and Ukraine following this
developing story Jonah Hull is going to
give us reaction from Keith Charles
Stratford is near the Ukrainian town of
bakmud recently taken over by Russian
forces the only shop of all of us in
Moscow first we're going to go to Ali
Hashem who's in Donetsk Ali we were
talking before about this Convoy of
Wagner fighters heading along the
motorway to Moscow also the Chechen
forces that are partly being sent to the
area to help what details do you have
about what's happening
the president of the regional Republic
of chechnya announced that he is citing
by President Putin and that's expected
his army his his Fighters left uh dunia
that was a very big Convoy that headed
towards rostov and the main mandate is
taking back control this is what his
forces are saying now this is going to
add to the complication of the situation
rostov has been uh kind of taken by the
Wagner group Fighters since this morning
the commander of Wagner Evgeni pregosian
vowed yesterday to march to resolve and
from the stove he is going to march to
Moscow just in case the ministry of
defense and the Army commanders didn't
meet him and that didn't happen really
so what we are seeing right now is that
rostov is under a Wagner there's control
any way or another also another cities
like uh
and uh to the north towards Moscow there
is also elliptic that's also being taken
by the uh um by the Wagner troops
however in rostov there are reports of
an explosion that was had earlier there
were reports that the Wagner Fighters
were laying mines about pregosian denied
this and said they were removing mines
that were put in the past the picture is
very complicated this is the day that
Russia and Ukraine and the world will
will remember well because it's changing
the Status Quo changing the equation
changing the situation on the front line
with yesterday reports from the ministry
of defense that the Ukrainian forces are
going to make use of this and as Charles
said before this they are going to
exploit the situation in the earth that
we start and counter offensive towards
back
rather than the rain exporting dogs and
cats but there is nothing really in the
city we can hear bombardments here and
there we don't know if this is going or
coming towards the the area this is the
picture in general from here
this is this is the speculation isn't it
really how all of these developments are
going to shape the situation on the
battlefield and they're going to be lots
of questions and and ideas being floated
about what the end of this is going to
be like isn't it
well yes of course this is related not
just to Russia's front line with Ukraine
the war the the what the Russians call
the special operation has been depending
in a very big way the on on the Wagner
they were pivotal in uh Bak mood they
are pivotal and solidar so now with
forces leaving the front line the
chechens leaving the the the front line
this is going to be impacted in a very
big way and it's not only about Russia
and Ukraine it's also about the Russian
footprint around the world mainly in
Africa in Mali in Central African
Republic in Sudan in Libya in Syria this
is all going to be impacted by what's
happening over here by the at the end a
pregosian who used to be called The Ally
of Putin of the chef of Putin is now the
enemy of state and the man who was
taking part in Russia's war in Ukraine
or the Special Operation as the Russians
call it is now creating a kind of a war
within the war
Ali thank you very much indeed that's um
Ali Hashem talking to us from Don Yates
we're going to go to Moscow to speak to
Yulia Chapel valabat I understand that
there are more statements that are
coming out being made by evgeny
pregozian what he's has he been saying
well you're getting progression keeps
posting his statements on the internet
he prefers short audio messages where he
reacts to everything what's happening to
his Wagner group and their actions in
one of his latest messages he expanded
on a question why the Wagner group
enjoyed overwhelming support of the
whole the country and he carried on
saying that Wagner was extremely popular
among all the people and all the people
were happy to see them when they were
entering the rostov region but there
were actually a lot of words of support
for the Russian president as well
because as as we earlier reported it
seemed like there was a new form of
expression of loyalty to Vladimir Putin
from um well in some Circles of course
especially official circles and
basically officials and their social
media
networks they they used to write that
they used to mention their region you
know their organization and they used to
pose the word combination we are with
the president
precursion uh by the way confirmed that
the cash that the cash that had been
found uh near near his office in Saint
Petersburg itself to pay a compensation
to a military personnel there so that
was yet another statement of him and
earlier on during uh Vladimir Putin's
address to the nation he called on the
Russians military and law enforcement
agencies as well as those who
participated in the armed rebellion and
he called the actions of the Wagner
group treason a stubborn the bank and
promised imminent punishment and we now
see some reactions to those words from
analysts and they say Wagner is now in a
city with a large number of Civilian
population and the tough decisive
actions announced by the president will
have to be carried out in dense Urban in
areas where it's difficult to use
Aviation and heavy armored vehicles also
we know on the other hand they say that
the number of the Wagner group according
to pregosian is 25 000 people so they
say the Army will be able to defeat them
uh well pregosian also reacted to
Putin's words about the treason saying
that president was deeply wrong that
they were patriots of their country and
they would fight for their country and
will fight for corruption and
bureaucracy in that country so basically
he refused to surrender you know I'm
just looking at that shot behind you as
you're talking and talking to us now and
it looks pretty quiet that's of Central
Moscow obviously and it looks pretty
quiet things seem to be moving normally
there are security measures that have
been taken all over Russia just talk us
through what's happening there
thank you
well actually it's quite easy to see
pieces of military equipment in the
center of Moscow right now but you're
right relatively it is quite calm also
heads of several regions ask their
people to remain at home as long as they
uncertainty continues in the country in
Moscow anti-terrorist measures have been
imposed introduced the police controlled
the roads in and around Moscow several
fighter chairs were spotted in resign
region earlier on also there were
reports about a huge traffic jam in uh
in in the rostov and varonis region
regions and we know that hundreds of
people have been stuck there for quite a
long time and there were also there were
also reports about armored vehicles on
the roads of those regions as well
um some armored military personnel
carriers earlier on was spotted in the
streets of Moscow but generally it's
it's it's quiet it's it's calm now well
security measures have been tightened
here and not just here in Moscow but in
other parts of the country too so under
almost important facilities have been
taken under protection and there are
also reports that all the public
activities have been canceled and things
like proms at schools and other venues
have been postponed at least for a week
yeah Julia thank you very much this is
again as you've been talking to me I was
just looking at some of the uh the
newswires one Reuters wire that has come
up saying it's quoting the Vedder musty
newspaper Russian soldiers set up a
machine gun position on the southwestern
edge of Moscow let's not forget that
apparently there is a convoy of Wagner
Fighters which is making its way up the
M4 heading towards Moscow we can't
confirm any of that of course but we
will bring more on that as we have it
now Alexander solve the above is
Chairman of the Russian opposition party
open Russia and he's joining us from
Limassol in Cyprus very good to have you
with us sir thank you very much indeed
um if any pregosian and the senior
commanders that he has been criticizing
for several months have all been
appointed by Vladimir Putin How much
damage could all of this do to the
president
well the the weirdest thing is that uh
he's guinea pig ocean is also has been
uh you know raised by Vladimir Putin so
everything has been made by Vladimir
Putin in this situation I think uh that
the biggest damage comes from the
realization of the of the elites of the
biggest part of the elites that Vladimir
Putin has showed his weakness absolutely
because I mean during the whole night
um a lot of things are happening and
it's it looked like no one no one was
even brave enough to wake him up so uh
and in his statement in the morning he
he never pronounced his name and he
again he was talking like just like
about navalny without even pronouncing
exact names exact figures exact data so
I mean his speech was again super weak
and super vague uh nothing serious
nothing uh in particular uh so uh I mean
so as as I've already mentioned probably
the biggest threat from all what is
happening right now for Vladimir Putin
is the fact that he is weak he looks
different than weak four the four four
Elites our correspondent Julie
chapovalova was saying that if Guinea
pigrosian forgive me pragosan has been
saying that Wagner has the support of
the Russian people how accurate is that
well in factors became extremely popular
popular during the last year and a half
this is true because
um you know uh he well first of all we
should mention that he is part of the
criminal uh probably even gang
surrounding Vladimir Putin uh but uh he
uses his Charisma and he uses a special
kind of rhetoric uh which is like which
has a very big social support so he says
social approvable things for example he
has he uses this anti Elite rhetoric he
says he constantly says that the
unpleasant truth is that is that we've
lost everything because of those
kleptocrats and uh surrounding Vladimir
Putin and because of those chain rules
he constantly lie to Vladimir Putin and
Vladimir Putin is completely deprived
from reality because of those uh who
surround him and he does not know the
truth only we do know and my comrades so
things like this and uh when uh for
example when drones were attacking
Moscow region he said that listen the
so-called which is the uh the district
where the elites leave he said let's I
don't care about this
even if ukrainians just burn it uh
uh I do only care about common faults so
you know he is indeed popular but I'm
not sure that that makes it possible for
him to convince the whole population to
join him or he doesn't need the whole
population the most important thing that
he needs right now to convince the
regular forces uh to join him at least
the part of regular forces so I I assume
that this Mutiny would be
pressed very soon the biggest chances
but he still has uh quite significant
chances I mean bigger than zero uh for
something significant to to to to to to
accomplish Alexander so love you we
appreciate you being with us so thank
you very much indeed for your time
thank you
Babbage is a political analyst and he
says Putin would not give in to pressure
from the Wagner chief
or I don't see any other possible
outcome but the big ocean surrender or
maybe some kind of a deal between him
and the ministry of Defense but
certainly Wagner group will not exist
any longer in its current formation
because let me remind you that Putin
never sees to pressure that is his very
important uh element of his character uh
even during the terrorist acts when
hundreds of people were held as human
Shields he never sealed to pressure and
the more pressure was applied to him the
harsher was his response obviously
precaution had been personally connected
to Putin for many years and Putin values
his friends so Putin allowed him to
criticize the ministry of defense and
many other things but in the last few
days pregosian just started speaking
like Ukrainian propaganda I mean listen
to his latest interview so uh the fact
that he basically turned again since the
government against the country you know
I talked to a lot of people in Moscow
they are all against precaution they all
say that we need Unity now in the times
of war and no one supports him uh
because it is obvious that he is a
successful businessman but that doesn't
make him a hero you know Russia does not
have a tradition of private armies
except the period of the Civil War and
Russia has no traditional military coups
not a single military coup was
successful in Russia there was just one
in 1825 which failed so uh history is on
Putin's side in this situation and the
majority of the population the public
opinion is on the side of pujan
precaution made his demands for more
ammunition probably for more money but I
also don't see how precaution can
motivate these fighters to go against
Moscow because obviously where does get
his money from to pay away the soldiers
from the Russian state budget obviously
so going against Moscow is basically
destroying uh the the sources uh for for
his private military company which was
modeled after the American companies
such as Blackwater and Academy which did
most of the uh bloody walk during the
Iraqi War uh you know I think the logic
of the Russian government was that if
Americans have private military
companies if this is the Modern Warfare
we should do something similar but
unfortunately the experiment failed and
we saw it this morning
well John Stratford is joining me now
from the road to bachmud in eastern
Ukraine Charles you and the team have
been in a village on the front line what
are the implications for the fighting
which has been going on
I think potentially this has very big
implications indeed it's going to be
interesting to see just how many Russian
troops Russian forces are going to have
to be committed to deal with this crisis
back from the front lines inside Russia
certainly According to some of the
Ukrainian forces that we've been
speaking to here as you say we're on the
road which of course was taking control
of by Russian forces a few weeks ago and
of course Wagner was so fundamental to
the victory in that battle the Ukrainian
soldiers that we've spoken to someone
said that they're going to exploit the
chaos that is that has happened on the
Russian controlled side of the front
lines of course this is very much in the
early stages of this Ukrainian
counter-offensive and we've seen um up
until now certainly the first couple of
weeks the ukrainians have struggled to
make great gains these probing attacks
that we've seen in various locations
along the front line certainly in this
area over the last few two hours it's
safe to say we've seen what could be
considered to be quite heavy troop
movements a lot of armored personnel
carriers and heavy Weaponry being moved
around there was quite a lot of shelling
both incoming and outgoing we understand
um until about an hour ago we've also
seen helicopters in this area which we
understand to be infantry carrying
helicopters so yeah this crisis inside
Russia does have some real implications
for this counter-offensive we've looked
at two different sections along the
Thousand kilometer front line to try and
gauge some of the challenges that the
Ukrainian forces are facing as I say in
the early stages of this operation and
this is our report
Russian forces have withdrawn from what
remains of this part The Village its
people have fled
I destroyed Ukrainian military vehicle
it's towed from the battlefield
dead Russian soldiers in the grass
the Ukrainian military last week
announced it had completely retaken The
Village
but that's not quite true
the crater you can see here is as a
result of a Russian airstrike
yesterday the Ukrainian military are
telling us that
although they've cleared so they say the
majority of this Village there is still
ongoing fighting on the outskirts
and they say they are facing Fierce
resistance from Russian forces
Ukraine's counter-offensive was expected
for months and that gave Russian forces
time to prepare to they have strong air
power and a lot of infantry supported by
Heavy Artillery they're moving slowly
towards us but we're killing them we're
conducting small offensive operations on
the outskirts of the village along the
Forest Lane but there are many mines
around 200 kilometers North near the
russian-occupied town of cremina barrage
after barrage of artillery fire Echoes
through the forests
Ukrainian soldiers here are nervous
Russian positions are a few hundred
meters away
Ukrainian forces retook this area during
a counter-offensive last summer neither
side has made a major advance for months
but as the Ukrainian Army began to probe
for weakness in Russian defenses to the
south things here began to change
honestly there is nothing good here the
situation is very tense
the trench Commander tells us to take
cover because Russian helicopter
gunships are in the area
there is constant fire from mortars
artillery helicopters airstrikes and
Small Arms they assault opposition in
small groups they are trying to break
through to capture an important Supply
route
hard craft and early days says Ukraine
and its NATO backers
if there ever is a decisive breakthrough
it could take months Charles traffic Al
Jazeera eastern Ukraine
Alexandre Volkswagens is a security and
defense policy analyst and
editor-in-chief of the Swiss military
review he's in Geneva and he's with us
live welcome to the program good to have
you with us
um the Ukrainian soldiers have been
saying I've certainly been telling our
correspondent that they are going to
take advantage of this they're going to
exploit the chaos I think was the word
he used and push towards back back mood
but this all seems to have taken the
ukrainians by as much surprises it
appears to have done with the Russian
forces are they actually in a position
to make any Capital out of this
well nothing is going to change on the
front line in the next uh probably two
days simply because all of the units of
the Russian armed forces are equipped
for uh two days autonomy in ammunition
they also have their plans for the next
48 hours so it's a very unlikely that
anything is going to change dramatically
however after these initial 48 Hours as
you have said there are possibilities of
concentrating or taking back a certain
number of forces in order to deal with a
new situation and so yes in the in the
near future there are many opportunities
that that are looming ahead for Ukraine
is it possible to speculate how many
troops and what kind of equipment the
Russians would have to pull back from
the the front in order to be able to
deal with the Wagner Fighters
speculate no it's not possible to do
that but let me say this if Russia is uh
if around the Russian military and
political leadership is well advised and
if they know their history they will
definitely not try to take troops that
have been committed to the front and
pull them back into the national
territory in order to deal with this
Insurgency and this for many different
reasons first of all you are talking
about veteran troops that may perhaps in
some cases feel a lot of sympathy for
these War veterans that are mercenaries
from the the Wagner group and so this
could potentially create a situation of
a very
contagious situation within the armed
forces and this is extremely risky and
secondly this is essentially an interior
issue it is an issue that will need to
be dealt with by the ministry of the
interior which has forces uh available
of lesser quality than pregosian's
mercenary so it is definitely an issue
and I think adding more Russian combat
troops depleting the front is just going
to create a lot uh more Hazard for
Russia if Kenny pagosian has said that
Wagner Fighters have been attacked by
Russian forces we've also heard from the
leader of the Chechen fighters who are
also on the front line on behalf of
Russia saying he's going to bring in
some troops to deal with the Wagner
Fighters if this turns into a prolonged
internal conflict and we are talking
about Wagner fighters who are very
experienced in fighting certainly over
the last several months or so what kind
of impact is that an unstable Russia
going to have
um how how long do you want to talk
about this yes the consequences are
extremely extremely grave and this could
turn into a protracted fight given the
fact that uh pregosians soldiers
mercenaries know all of the strengths
and also the weaknesses of the Russian
army they know where the arms Depots are
located and so it is not completely
surprised that they would have targeted
and taken control of rostov where a lot
of the control and Logistics facilities
are and so yes the Russian military is
is right now in a bit of a difficult
situation having to deal with one uh
very sizable uh situation and and
trouble keep in mind the people who are
following pregocian's orders this
represents something like 12 percent of
all of the military forces committed to
the Ukraine war so all of a sudden the
Ukraine's ukrainians are seen 10 to 12
percent of the defensive uh forces of
Russia gone and Russia has to deal with
with this very sizable problem it's
really interesting to get your thoughts
in this Alexander voltravis we
appreciate it thank you very much indeed
well meanwhile there's been no pause in
Russia's offensive in Ukraine we're
going to cross live to Jonah Hall in
cave Jonah how are Ukraine's political
leadership viewing what's going on in
Russia at the moment
uh well one imagines with an element of
caution uh they won't want to be
assuming too much certainly that this is
going to be any sort of Turning Point or
at least just yet but at the same time
Keen uh to highlight what they perceive
to be Russia's vulnerabilities those are
the sort of notes coming out of some of
the comments we've heard from Vladimir
zielinski talking about Russia's
weakness being obvious in these events
the longer Russia keeps its troops and
mercenaries on our land the more chaos
pain and problems it will have to face
later uh dimitro culeba the foreign
minister taking the opportunity to call
on Ukraine's allies for more help more
equipment that they need to end the war
those who think Russia is too strong to
lose he wrote look at what's happening
now but perhaps the most insightful
comment comes from Michaela podoliak
he's a senior advisor to Vladimir
zelinski who believes things will move
very quickly now over the next 48 hours
he wrote uh will be determined the new
status in Russia either he believes a
civil war
or some sort of contractual transition
to power or He suggests this is just the
latest stage in a gradual disintegration
of the Putin regime as he put it and
that I think illustrates the way in
which these events are being viewed as
part of a scenario that has probably
been anticipated here in Ukraine from
the very beginning of this war the way
that it would eventually unfold they
would have believed would would be in
terms of split splits if the elite
splits within the military disagreements
over the long-term objectives of the war
disagreements perhaps over perceived
military failures that therefore lead to
feuds and confrontations that in turn
weaken the Kremlin and crucially
challenge the idea of Vladimir Putin as
an all-powerful authoritative leader and
therefore in turn lead to some sort of
change of calculus in the war I think
that's the prism through which these
events are being viewed here and if
they've been planning for those splits
as you were saying one can imagine that
they're going to have some sort of
military response to this do we have any
indication how this might play out in
terms of a military strategy
foreign
the guests we've just been listening to
there again it's a watch and wait isn't
it but fascinating uh these developments
in roster Von Dawn and what effect they
may have on Russia's overall command and
control structures it is the
headquarters absolute linchpin in the
war effort the headquarters of the
Southern military District that is in
charge of all the war planning here so
you can be sure Ukraine's military
planners will be looking for any signs
of the extent of disruption that may be
going on in those command and control
structures the extent of disruption to
supply lines
and so on but more specifically along
the front line I think the concentration
would be to try and figure out just what
sort of vulnerabilities may have been
exposed by the departure of Wagner
mercenaries from strongholds along that
front line including places like
backwood in the East and what sort of
opportunities but those may open up for
Ukraine's ongoing counter-offensive
Jonah thank you very much indeed there's
Jonah Hall talking to us from Keith
well Antonio is a Ukrainian political
scientist and director of the center for
Democratic Integrity he's joining us
from Vienna very good to have you with
us on Al Jazeera moving away from the
military strategy side of this in
political terms how can Ukraine best use
this situation to its advantage
well I think that Ukraine has warned
many for many months now that an
internal conflict was awaiting Russia
and this is something that uh that the
Ukrainian leadership predicted and also
if you see it or if You observe the
developments in the in in the Russian
Federation or in in previous uh recent
years actually you could see that what
is happening today is not only the
product of the big war of the full-blown
invasion of Ukraine that started
Discovery last year but it's also is
underpinned by a very deeply seated
social conflict in the Russian
Federation and I think this is what
Ukraine also sees why this conflict is
so also a social conflict is because
um uh there is an elite Russian leads
who are enjoying life in Saint
Petersburg and Moscow and that there are
poor regions that are being depleted now
people are sent to the front lines to
Ukraine they are dying there in masses
the elites the Russian Elites are using
them as Canon folders as Canon fodder
for the objectives that nobody really
understands why they are fighting this
useless war against Ukraine and Ukraine
has been saying this for months and
months now that this is this is a
useless war and of course this gives
Ukraine an opportunity to carry out the
counter-offensive much more efficiently
and I wouldn't be surprised to know that
Ukraine has actually played some part in
in these military coup attempt by
preggers Wagner you mentioned before
that Ukraine has been expecting or
certainly anticipating this kind of uh
this split for some time presumably you
have some indication or some sort of
assessment about what the ultimate
situation is going to be within Russia
do you have any indication about whether
or not there is going to be any
significant change at the top in Russia
um well I think the situation develops
in the direction of really grave changes
uh in the well in the socio-political uh
life in the Russian Federation now the
war is coming back home and this has
been anticipated
um again for for many reasons and
Ukraine saw that of course and I think
it also somehow planned the
counter-offensive to to fight when when
the Ukrainian authorities are located or
identified the weak time framework for
this country offensive for a week for
for the Russian Federation
is there any likelihood do you think
that any changes that do subsequently
happen in Russia
will have any significant benefit to
Ukraine or make any significant
difference in terms of the the
battlefield reaction that we're likely
to see over the next few months or so
I think this is uh this is quite
definite but I also think that we will
see the changes not in several months
but I would say in the coming weeks uh
but honestly if we are looking at the
history of uh of Wars uh a link to
Russia somehow associated with Russia we
see that
a country cannot really wage a
successful War if there is an internal
conflict in in inside this country this
is how Russia lost the first world war
because of the revolution in most uh in
in Saint Petersburg so any any internal
conflict and this is what's happening
today is a huge internal conflict in in
Russia is beneficial for Ukraine it's
beneficial for the counter defense it is
good for the liberation of Ukrainian
cities and towns and Villages from the
Russian occupation
Anton shakotsov we appreciate you being
with us in Al Jazeera so thank you very
much indeed for your time